turbulent conditions are nothing new to
private Market veterans but as interest
rates climb to record Heights in 2022
many lost their stomach for New Deals
m&a volumes plummeted 48% in the first
quarter of 2023 as deals were put on
hold or cancelled outright many of the
most experienced managers have pivoted
from new money deals to add-on
Acquisitions but what what is an add-on
acquisition in private Equity an add-on
deal is when a portfolio company
acquires a business directly as opposed
to the
sponsor one of the reasons that add-ons
are achievable they tend to be smaller
they require less debt um add-ons can
often be financed by the existing
portfolio company off its balance sheet
we've seen this a lot in the veterinary
industry we've seen this a lot in
healthcare with different clinics where
a lot of times historically those have
been fragmented businesses buying mall
at a relatively low multiple aggregated
them into into a larger business that
hopes to then exit at a whole with all
the benefits of kind of synergies and
scale that you would expect despite
being relatively cheap compared to a
fully leveraged buyout add-ons are no
less complicated requiring a detailed
examination of company strategies
operating structures and legal
Frameworks so what are the principles
for anyone attempting such a
[Music]
deal so I think in that sense you you're
looking at how that Target company
operates you know how it deals with its
suppliers what its kind of overhead is
in terms of kind of managing HR um how
it operates its it systems getting into
the
details a lot of times realizing the
value will depend on being able to very
quickly execute on the integration plan
dealing with employees and legal
implications of looking to terminate
contracts and whether that's possible
even kind of more techy legal things of
you know you've got multiple operating
companies now in a particular
jurisdiction do you need them all
management incentivization is a key part
of any private Equity transaction as a
mechanism to align the interests of the
shareholder owners and the managers that
going to run the business going forward
if there is available Equity there can
often be uh a question around price
you're then acquiring a business with
its own uh Management in the in the
acquired asset and you need to consider
how and whether they're able to
integrate into the existing management
Equity plan with all that in mind
managers must still keep one eye on the
exit while the average holding period
for a leveraged buyout ranges from
around 3 to 5 years the integration of a
smaller business into a larger portfolio
can often take longer to yield results
but despite this the current shilled
economic climate and reduced
availability of Bank debt has actually
had the effect of making small add-on
Acquisitions more
[Music]
attractive faced with those
circumstances sponsors that perhaps
we're contemplating a near-term exit for
a particular portfolio company might
think that it's now 2 years away it's 3
years away we give that additional time
we've got now time to focus on this
company maybe execute on some of these
add-on transactions that we didn't think
we had time to do identifying the right
acquisition Target and at the right time
remain key to the success of add-on
Deals Deals that many portfolio managers
are turning to in these uncertain
Economic
[Music]
Times